saved by the bell is one of the most
iconic teen sitcoms of the 90s
but it's also a product of its time that
got away with things that wouldn't fly
nowadays
from dubious addictions to ill-advised
attempts at romance
here are the episodes that just wouldn't
happen today as a kid
you probably laughed along with super
cool teen heartthrob zack morris
as he got up to his zany exploits but
when you think about save by the bell
now
the first thing you realize is that zak
is quite possibly the worst person in
the world he's casually cruel to his
friends
he's constantly exploiting others to get
money and most of all
he's a total creep to the women who have
the bad luck to be trapped in the orphan
of his endless scheming
a perfect example with season two's
model students
in which the plot revolves around a
mixture of zack's two favorite hobbies
capitalism and revenge after utterly
failing to line his pockets by making
the school store a profitable business
he and screech decide to secretly take
pictures of the girls a swim team to
make calendars
this doesn't even lead to zach getting a
stern talking to instead
when a creepy photographer shows up in
pursuit of more salacious photos of
underage girls taken without their
consent
zach prays on his victim's desire for
fame and weasels his way
into becoming the girls manager if this
plot happened today
we'd hope that it would lead to less of
zach getting a 10 commission
and more of him meeting his comeuppance
fatal distraction might not be as bad as
some other save by the bell episodes
although it does feature zack dressed up
as a cartoonish arab stereotype in order
to better lie to women
so yeah it's still pretty awful the plot
finds zach bugging a sleepover at
jesse's house in order to get some
information that he can use to gaslight
kelly into going on a date with him some
viewers might recognize this as
essentially the plot of the tv show you
scaled down to high school it's also
pretty standard as far as that goes
the twist comes when the girls discover
zack's bug and decide to mess with him
by making him think that kelly
is criminally insane and will kill him
if they start dating
this episode wouldn't fly today for
several reasons first and foremost
illegal surveillance done to manipulate
someone into dating you is to
put it charitably frowned upon second if
you've been on tick tock lately
then you probably noticed that today's
teens are a little more sensitive and
far less likely to fake a mental illness
for revenge
third zak would obviously know something
was wrong with kelly's story
when he realized that he'd never heard
her tale on any true crime podcast
over the course of the series zack tries
to manipulate his classmates in ways
that would likely end with felony
charges today and probably should have
back then
one of his worst offenses has to be the
time he attempts to brainwash the school
through subliminal messages in order to
get a date to a dance
but his actions as reprehensible as they
are might not actually be the most
ill-advised behavior in the episode
when his plot is discovered the entire
school decides to turn the tables on him
with every girl bayside
swarming him while chanting his name it
makes sense that the students would want
this public revenge
where it goes off the rails though is
when the teachers get in on it
as well both principal belding and miss
wentworth engaged in fake seduction
attempts on zack who to be clear
is a high school freshman furthermore
the tape that miss wentworth makes to
teach the kids about subliminal messages
includes a line about how they should
hook her up with their single fathers
and if any of you have a handsome single
parent i'm available
if you look back now and think about
this episode for just two seconds
there's nothing about it that's not
truly horrifying
season one screech's woman features zach
pretending to be a girl named bambi in
order to seduce screech into doing all
the work on a group project
and you've probably already figured out
the problem here
all things considered though zack morris
catfishing one of his friends for
personal gain actually does seem like
the kind of plot that could work in the
21st century
if anything it's only gotten easier to
pull off a scam like this in the years
since this episode
aired the show even treats zack's
performance as bambi with a surprisingly
modern sensibility
sure it's played for laughs but unlike
similar setups among saved by the bell's
contemporaries
zack's challenge to the gender binary
isn't frowned upon by his friends
jesse and lisa help him pick out an
outfit and even slater seems to approve
this whole thing complimenting zach on
his looks when he finds him at the max
so what's the problem well it's mainly
that zack looks like holly from die hard
with wrestler gorilla monsoon sunglasses
there's no way that jesse and lisa would
let bambi go out of the house without a
better outfit if it were 20 20.
in season two's renault pop zack engages
in some highly relatable teenage hijanks
by hiring an
actor to impersonate his father at a
parent-teacher conference so that his
real dad
doesn't find out that he's been spending
all of his time at school on truly
upsetting schemes
that premise is already pretty
ridiculous but it's hardly unusual in tv
taking things one step past a logical
extreme is what makes a sitcom work
after all
and this is far from the wackiest thing
that's ever happened at bayside
ultimately the reasons this episode
wouldn't fly today are mostly related to
the technology that's been developed
over the past three decades
for one thing social media would make it
nearly impossible for zach to convince
mr belding
that an actor was his dad no matter how
good a performance he was turning in
second and far more pressing for today's
audience that episode title raises way
too many red flags
these days going out and finding an
out-of-work actor to pay to be your
daddy for a couple of hours has a very
different connotation save the max has
one of those reliable sitcom plots that
never seem to go out of style
a beloved institution is in danger of
financial ruin so to save it our beloved
characters have to put on a show
in this case the institution is the max
and the kids use the bayside high
student radio station for a call-in
telethon to raise money
before we move on what exactly is the
max as far as we can
tell it's basically a local hangout that
contains all school functions for some
reason or
a weirdly stylized cafeteria that the
kids hang out in after school
if anyone out there has a better
explanation please let us know because
we've been wondering about this for
three solid decades
no matter how you slice it save the max
is a bit dated
high school radio stations do still
exist but they're not quite as prominent
as they were before everyone started
carrying around a supercomputer in their
pocket that could access
virtually all media at all times if this
plot were pitched today
we'd be far more likely to get an
episode in which zack starts an official
bayside tick tock account in order to
smash
capitalism then change the subplot about
zach finding out that mr belding used to
be a cool team dj
by instead making him a former youtube
reviewer of classic video games who got
cancelled for being problematic
and now you've got something that's
hashtag relatable
one thing you have to give to running
zack in which young mr morris learns
that racist stereotypes are bad
is that its heart is in the right place
it's one of the few episodes that
actually addresses the fact that zach
is kind of a terrible person and shows
him trying to address that
and improve himself his methodology
though leaves quite a bit to be desired
on the one hand there are a lot of
individual pieces here that feel like
they could be relevant to today's
audience like jessie grappling with her
guilt over finding out that her
ancestors were slave traders
and pressuring lisa to absolve her of
her familial sense
also depicting chief henry as completely
shattering the stereotypical native
american
image held by zack was an admirable
choice on the part of the show
on the other hand zack showing up in
buck skins face paint and a war bonnet
identifying himself as running zach
because he's on the track team and
delivering his class presentation
in a stern monotone is less than ideal
my heart
is sad it's tough to imagine the story
resolving in quite the same way today
especially considering that while zach
morris the character is revealed to have
native ancestry mark paul goslar
the actor who played him does not no
matter how well intentioned it was
some justifiable complaints about red
face would have kept this one
on the cutting room floor most of the
memorable episodes of save by the bell
stand out because
of how weird they are and how far they
wander from their generic roots
zach cradling an oil covered duck in the
show's most intense display of emotion
or zack and screech fooling the
government with an alien encounter hoax
are pretty bizarre when you get right
down
to it snow white and the seven dorks on
the other hand is about as standard
issue
as a sitcom can get the plot of two
characters having an on-stage romance
and a school play that causes them to
question their real-life feelings for
each other is ready-made drama and so
are the scenes in which jessie tries to
keep her secret by getting extremely
weird about it
it's such a well-worn formula that it's
hard to imagine a show dusting it off
today without doing something to subvert
it nevertheless
as long as schools have drama
departments and hormonal theater kids
it's going to be a reliable premise
what really wouldn't work today though
is the actual play within the play
itself
saved by the bell wasn't exactly high
art to begin with so we can forgive it
for being a little cheesy but pop
culture has thankfully moved past the
idea that doing a so-called rap version
of a song should consist of a bunch of
people simply talking at each other
over a casio keyboard rigby with the
cadence of a fruity pebbles commercial
dork number five i gotta disagree if you
want snow white alive
don't look at me if you know only one
episode of save by the bell
it's probably jesse's song the infamous
very special episode that deals with the
pressing issue of teen addiction
to caffeine the original concept for the
episode was that jessie would get
addicted to amphetamines in her pursuit
of academic perfection
unfortunately nbc's standards and
practices department didn't actually
want to show a teenager doing drugs
which made things a little difficult as
the script had already been written
ultimately jesse's illegal uppers were
swapped out for caffeine pills without
changing anything else about the script
as a result her reaction to ingesting
the equivalent of about five
cups of coffee is a manic breakdown of
truly epic proportions
i'm so excited i'm so
excited i'm so
scared it's pretty tough to imagine this
one making it to the air nowadays
although it was admittedly weird even at
the time the problem isn't the subject
matter so much as the execution
it's presented as completely serious
without ever crossing the line into
comedy
despite elizabeth berkeley and mark paul
gossler's admirably intense efforts it
never really makes much sense
just compare this episode to a teen show
of today like riverdale in which a high
school sophomore spends her afternoons
operating a secret speakeasy to be fair
these two shows take very different
approaches to their subject matter but
if we told you that one of them involved
a kid with the unexplained ability to
stop time
and you didn't know which one it was
would you really be able to guess
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you